hi it's michelle from lab muffin beauty
science chemistry phd cosmetic chemist
and big fan of vitamin c vitamin c is
one of the most raved about ingredients
in skin care and there's so much
evidence to back up its effects but it's
also one of the most confusing there are
just so many different vitamin c
ingredients and product types and that's
before you get down to all the different
products you can buy so this is going to
be a bumper guide to vitamin c and i'm
going to have to split it into two
separate videos in this one i'm going to
focus on the form of vitamin c with the
most evidence ascorbic acid and it also
happens to be the fussiest drama queen
i'm going to be talking about what it
does how to use it the different product
types and some product recommendations
in part two i'm going to talk about the
other versions of vitamin c the
derivatives these are great if your skin
is too sensitive for ascorbic acid or
you just can't handle how confusing
ascorbic acid is so why is everyone so
obsessed with vitamin c and skin care
well it's because of the amount of
evidence behind it it's one of the best
studied ingredients in skincare in the
grand hierarchy of skincare and greeting
categories if retinoids were up here
vitamin c would be maybe around here
just below it and specifically its
ascorbic acid we're talking about
ascorbic acid is the best studied and
most common type of vitamin c you'll
find in skin care products it's actual
vitamin c the same stuff you find in
oranges and in supplements a side note
sometimes you'll see people say it has
to be l-ascorbic acid and not just
ascorbic acid the reality is pure
l-ascorbic acid is the cheapest kind of
ascorbic acid you can get so all the
ascorbic acid that you find in skincare
and supplements is going to be
l-ascorbic acid
l-ascorbic acid has been found to have
these effects on skin it can increase
collagen in the skin this is probably
the most exciting effect vitamin c is
involved in making collagen and
cross-linking it so that it makes a nice
firm solid network
some of the enzymes involved in this
proline and lysol hydroxylase need
vitamin c to work vitamin c might also
be able to block the action of matrix
metalloproteinase one this is an enzyme
that breaks down collagen in the skin it
can also help with wound healing such as
after you have a fractional laser
treatment and it also boosts pigment
reduction and that's the other big
skincare concern that vitamin c can help
with it can reduce pigments such as sun
spots and post acne marks and melasma
ascorbic acid interferes with the
production of melanin which is the brown
pigment in your skin the exact way it
does this still isn't entirely confirmed
but it interferes with the enzyme
tyrosinase and stops it from doing its
job properly vitamin c can also help
protect skin from sun damage it doesn't
stop uv like sunscreen but it acts as an
antioxidant that mops up the damage that
uv does inside your skin one of the big
reasons uv is bad for skin is that it
produces free radicals i have another
video that goes into detail about free
radicals and antioxidants but basically
free radicals are really reactive
substances that smash into lots of
different parts of your skin causing
generalized damage sort of like a bull
in a china shop antioxidants can soak up
this damage provided they can actually
get into your skin where the free
radicals are and ascorbic acid can get
into your skin in one of the classic pig
skin vitamin c studies they needed twice
as much uv to turn skin red after it had
been treated with 15 l ascorbic acid
adding one percent vitamin e doubled
that and adding point five percent
fluoric acid doubled that again meaning
that this combo gave a total of eight
times the uv protection there were
similar results when vitamin c was used
with ferulic acid and fluoritan on human
skin vitamin c has also been shown to
reduce some of the skin damaging changes
that infrared radiation can cause in
your skin there's also evidence that can
protect against ozone and diesel exhaust
which are true pollutants you find in
urban areas also in some of these
studies they found that people who
didn't get enough vitamin c in their
diet had bigger improvements in their
skin so
unsurprisingly a balanced diet is good
for your skin so how do you use an
ascorbic acid product studies have
generally tested ascorbic acid products
at between 3 and 25
and like for many other skin care
actives i think lower percentages are
actually underrated higher percentages
can be really irritating and a lot of
studies have actually used lower
percentages like three and five percent
so you don't actually have to go very
high to see benefits out of all the
skincare ingredients i think ascorbic
acid is definitely one where you can get
diminishing returns if you go too high
i'd recommend starting at under 10 and
then going up or down depending on how
that goes you might even need to stop it
altogether because a lot of people do
find ascorbic acid too irritating there
are also some fruits that are very high
in ascorbic acid so for example kakadu
plum is about 12 ascorbic acid by dry
weight but usually with fruit acids it
can be really difficult to work out
exactly what percentage you have because
extracts vary a lot in terms of how
concentrated they are so if you want
something more reliable i'd recommend
looking for a product that has straight
ascorbic acid with layering i'd
recommend using ascorbic acid as close
to your bare skin as possible so one of
the first steps after cleansing because
it's not very good at getting into skin
ascorbic acid can go with most other
skin care products the only hard no's i
can think of are copper ions so any of
those blue copper products
and benzoyl peroxide both of these will
inactivate the ascorbic acid it's a myth
that you can't use ascorbic acid with
niacinamide kind of steven has debunked
this thoroughly on his blog i recommend
being careful with other irritating
skincare ingredients like hydroxy acid
exfoliants and retinoids they can go
together but you have to be really
careful otherwise you'll burn your face
off actually there's one more ingredient
in compatibility that i discovered when
i used them together on my face and that
is i had an eyebrow pencil that went
bright orange when i used it with
ascorbic acid it had ferric ammonium
ferrocyanide in it so be careful with
that one you can use vitamin c morning
or night if you use it in the morning
you'll probably get more of those uv
protection benefits but it's believed
that vitamin c has a depot effect so in
other words one application lasts more
than 24 hours in your skin
in pigskin it was 72 hours so using it
at night will probably get there too it
is a myth that vitamin c is
photosensitizing it will actually
improve your resistance to uv i think
this myth comes from the fact that alpha
hydroxy acids are photosensitizing and
then people assume that all acids were
but in fact no acids are apart from
alpha hydroxy acids now the big problem
with vitamin c is there is so much
variation when it comes to vitamin c
products not all forms of vitamin c have
been shown to have all these amazing
beneficial effects in human skin some
might have had one effect in a study but
it wasn't a very high quality study so
you can't really say much for sure some
of them are pretty unlikely to work at
all and with every variation it depends
a lot on the specific formula here's
where i'm going to introduce the lab
muffin matrix for figuring out whether
or not a skincare product will actually
work i'll talk more about this in a
later video and to be honest i haven't
really fleshed it out properly but these
are some of the things you want to be
thinking about you want to see if the
active ingredients can theoretically
work and if the active ingredients have
been shown to actually work on human
skin in clinical trials a lot of things
that could theoretically work don't
actually work when you put them on a
complex system like human skin if
everything that theoretically worked
actually worked on humans then we would
have cured cancer thousands of times
over you also want to see if that
specific formula could theoretically
work and then if it's actually worked on
human skin in clinical trials some
ingredients are really easy to formulate
with so you don't have to do too much
guesswork here but other ones are a lot
trickier ascorbic acid there are a few
really annoying things about l-ascorbic
acid firstly l-ascorbic acid is pretty
unstable and it breaks down relatively
quickly to inactive dehydroascorbic acid
when it's being ionized this happens
faster when it's in water when it's at a
high ph so when it's alkaline and when
it's exposed to light and oxygen this
process is called oxidation because
oxygen is usually involved this means
your product gets less effective over
time and how quickly this happened
depends a lot on the formula when it
breaks down it starts off colorless then
it goes yellow then orange than brown so
you can sort of get a visual indication
of how active your vitamin c probably is
so looking at the lab muffin matrix
elescopic acid ticks off these two boxes
really well there are tons of studies on
it or at least tons of studies by
cosmetic ingredient standards but it's
in these two other boxes where things
get incredibly dicey and it's largely
because of this instability how much
ascorbic acid you actually have depends
so much on the formula the packaging and
how long you've had it it is probably
one of the trickiest ingredients for
this part on top of whether or not it
works decomposed vitamin c is just plain
annoying because it stains after the
ascorbic acid breaks down a few times it
turns into a chemical called erythrulose
this is a component of fake tan and that
means your decomposed vitamin c can
stain your face and your skin this isn't
harmful but it's also not designed to be
a fake tan product so it doesn't go on
very evenly and it gives you that
metallic soy sauce sort of smell and
this decomposition speeds up after
you've applied it to your skin obviously
your skin is going to have more oxygen
and more light than in a bottle so even
a very stable formula can give you nasty
stained yellow fingers for days ascorbic
acid is usually formulated to be at a
relatively low ph below 3.5 to help it
get into the skin when the ph is higher
then more of the ascorbic acid will be
charged and charged things don't get
into skin very easily this was actually
the topic of my very first youtube video
having a low ph also helps keep it
stable and sometimes the ph is lower
than it needs to be because of legal
reasons moving on to the different
formulation types let's start with ce
ferulic the best researched ascorbic
acid formulation is the skinceutical c e
ferrulic formula the scientist who did
most of the peer-reviewed research on
vitamin c's effects on skin was dr
sheldon pannell he patiented a
particular formulation and his son
started the skincare company's
skinceuticals which is now owned by
l'oreal the patient which is commonly
called the duke patient is pretty broad
as well as covering the sea ceopharylic
formula which was the formulation
developed from all of these studies into
vitamin c
it also covers any formula with pure
ascorbic acid at 10 to 20 concentration
and a ph between 2 and 3.5
so in other words the formulations where
vitamin c seems to perform best now
these aren't really hard and fast rules
a lot of the early studies were done on
pigskin and it isn't like it doesn't
work at lower percentages there are
clinical trials where three and five
percent worked really well anyway this
is why scientists and dermatologists
always rave about the skinceutical
c-e-ferylic formula this is literally
the formula that's the culmination of
all of this ascorbic acid research it's
really rare to have a non-drug product
that scores really well in all of the
boxes on the lab muffin matrix this
product basically does the best out of
all the skin care products that aren't
regulated as drugs the other
skinceuticals vitamin c serums also use
patient combinations they've subbed out
the vitamin e to make it less oily and
thick and so it works better for oily
skin there's fluorite and cf which is
recommended for discoloration and silly
marine cf which is recommended for oily
acne prone skin and again there's lots
of studies on these which means they get
good marks in all of these departments
the obvious downside is that these are
really expensive not everyone wants to
pay this much or can pay this much even
if it is the gold standard rolls royce
of all vitamin c products slash all
non-drug skin care products and it still
does eventually break down it's not 100
stabilized they say it's fine for six
months after opening the patient
suggests that it'll be fine for more
than a year so what are the other
options you could look for a copycat
vitamin c vitamin e and ferulic acid
serum there are some that violate the
patient and l'oreal just haven't gone
around to suing them yet and there are
some that get around the patient by
messing around with the formula for
example some of them go outside the ph
range that skinceuticals has bags with
their patent some of them might go lower
than the already pretty extreme ph range
and i think that's why some people think
their skin can't handle vitamin c as a
scientist who worked in r d i know how
important patents are in getting
companies to invest in innovation
so i'm a bit ethically conflicted about
trying to work out which products do and
don't violate the patent so i'm just
going to list a bunch of popular
products that have vitamin c e and
ferylic acid there's timeless poreless
choice malev geek and gorgeous and
osceuticals i recommend you look up
reviews to get a gauge of which one
might be right for you are they as good
as the skinceuticals ones well obviously
the overall formula doesn't have the
same level of evidence but anecdotally
from people who have tried both some
people find the skinceuticals formula
much more gentle and more effective
whereas other people can't really tell
the difference so i think it really
depends on how picky your skin is and
what you want out of a vitamin c product
for shorter term effects like pigment
then anecdotal evidence is going to be a
bit more useful for longer term effects
like collagen production you're probably
going to want more clinical evidence
because it's hard to see what's going on
just by eye you could also track down
the ingredients and diy something very
similar to the skinceuticals formula by
following the patent michelle is not a
lawyer do not trust her do not check
this as legal advice she is not
responsible if laurie i'll break down
your door and sue you for patent
infringement this is a bit of an
investment both time and money wise but
it could pay off if you commit to doing
it so if you're not sure whether or not
your skin even likes vitamin c then it's
probably not as good an idea if you want
to go down this route holy snails has a
tutorial on her blog there are also lots
of other antioxidant combos that work
apart from just vitamin e and ferulic
acid this combo is mostly what dr
pinnell published his peer-reviewed
research papers on which is why everyone
uses it but even in the original patient
this wasn't the only combo there are
tons of combinations in the patient and
there are a million antioxidants out
there so some of them will definitely
work as well also pharylic acid is
mostly what's causing that hot dog water
smell there's a bit of vitamin c in
there as well but it is mostly the
feralic acid so if you hate that smell
then it might be worth looking for one
that doesn't use this combo i recommend
looking for a product where the brand
has tested it out properly in terms of
stability and clinical results because
now the lab muffin matrix is looking a
bit sadder on this side one example of a
good one would be the ultraceuticals one
i'm sure there are others out there it's
also possible to stabilize ascorbic acid
in other ways you can use special
airtight packaging unfortunately a lot
of airless pumps aren't actually airless
so they don't protect the vitamin c
properly from oxidation it's also
difficult to find pumps that don't have
metal springs in them and that metal
will rust and decompose with the vitamin
c so that means your packaging breaks
plus that extra metal will deactivate
vitamin c faster but it is possible to
get special packaging that works for
example the roto milano cc has a special
airtight tube you have to squeeze it
really hard to get any product to come
out you can also use colloidal gold i
know colloidal gold sounds really
gimmicky but they have some really cool
applications in drug delivery this is
basically getting substances where they
need to be to work which is very
relevant to skin care someone in my phd
research group was actually studying
gold particles the way it works is
ascorbic acid is bonded technical word
conjugated to tiny gold particles the
ones used in skincare are generally just
too big to be categorized as
nanoparticles the gold also has
glutathione on it which is another
antioxidant it's almost like a vitamin c
derivative except it's still listed as
ascorbic acid in the ingredients list
the extra bond stabilizes it and the
ascorbic acid doesn't come off the gold
particle until it's in your skin so that
means it's fine at a higher ph the
manufacturer recommends 3.5 to 6.5 and
because it gets into your skin a lot
more easily and it's a lot more stable
that means a lower percentage of
ascorbic acid bonded to gold will be as
effective as a higher percentage of a
regular ascorbic acid product there are
products from naturium and murad which
use this technology there are also
vitamin c derivatives which is a whole
different kettle of fish i'll go into
more detail about those in part two of
my vitamin c guide so that is
water-based ascorbic acid products like
i mentioned ascorbic acid is pretty
unstable when it's dissolved in water
but what if we get a product where it's
not dissolved in water where you maybe
dissolve it yourself that means you
don't have to worry as much about how
long the product's been sitting around
waiting decomposing before it gets to
you or even going through some pretty
gnarly destabilizing temperature changes
there are a few different categories of
these products there's the very simple
diy formula that i talked about in an
earlier video i forgot to put on my lab
coat this formula is super basic with no
penetration enhances and you're probably
going to have to remake it every few
weeks or so because it does break down
plus the only preservative is the low ph
but because it's so fresh a lot of
people do see better results with this
than an older pre-made more stable
vitamin c serum this is the cheapest
option but it does take time i've had a
lot of questions about this diy serum
some people have claimed that it
couldn't possibly work but i don't think
those arguments make much scientific
sense having the ascorbic acid
crystallize out after you've put it on
your skin isn't a big issue i'll talk
about this in a bit but solid ascorbic
acid crystals can work on skin ascorbic
acid is stable enough to last a few
months after you've dissolved it this
has been reported in the literature and
i've done a few experiments myself to
see how long it lasts so i'll talk about
that in a later video i've also had a
lot of questions about adding things to
it like glycerin and aloe vera i
generally wouldn't recommend it because
there's no extra preservative here it's
at a very low ph which means that
there's a low microbial risk but if you
start adding stuff into it that feeds
bacteria and fungi that's going to up
the risk so i'm not really comfortable
recommending that same with keeping it
for a longer period of time like it
could be fine but there's also a good
chance it won't be so if you do try that
be really careful and don't say i didn't
warn you michelle is not responsible if
you make this and mess up your face she
bloody warned you if you do want to make
it more complicated i recommend checking
out that holy snails blog post and
tweaking that there are also products
where the ascorbic acid comes as a
separate powder and it's already
pre-measured and you just dump the whole
lot into a base serum drunk elephant
recently came out with one there's also
been some from the body shop and
clinique so those are also an option
there are also just jars of ascorbic
acid powder that you can buy and you
dissolve a little bit into your serum
right before you apply it the ordinary
has one and i don't really like these
i've talked about why before you need a
really tiny amount of ascorbic acid per
application three drops of a 10 vitamin
c serum converts to 1 50th of a tic tac
and that's really hard to measure out
that means it's really variable how much
you're applying you could be applying
too much like 40
plus when you just dissolve the powder
without adjusting the ph afterwards then
you generally end up with a much lower
ph than you want it's going to be more
irritating so i'm born against doing
that it might be okay if you have really
resilient skin or if you put it on
thicker body skin maybe if you mix it
into a really soothing product but i
think there are much safer options that
won't mess up your barrier also if you
decide not to listen to me and do it
anyway it's probably cheaper if you buy
nutritional ascorbic acid and a mortar
and pestle so you can grind it up finely
there are also water free products these
have ascorbic acid but it's ground out
really finely and then suspended into an
oily base ascorbic acid doesn't ionize
an oil so it's pretty stable like this
then when you apply to your skin it
slowly dissolves in the water that's
always evaporating off your skin this is
where trans epidermal water loss comes
from this is also why the so-called
crystallization of ascorbic acid isn't a
problem when you're doing a diy serum
ultraceuticals have published a peer
review paper on what i'm assuming is the
ultra c23 plus firming concentrate this
has the ascorbic acid in a silicone base
and it's had a lot of those really nice
vitamin c effects on tiny skin samples
l'oreal revitalift 10 pure vitamin c
serum is another good one a lot of the
time when it's a really big brand like
l'oreal you can probably assume they've
tested it there are a few other brands
that have had similar products too like
the ordinary and polish choice there are
also a couple of pre-made ascorbic acid
and silicone ingredients that can be
used to formulate these sorts of
products really easily the biggest
problem with these is that the ascorbic
acid crystals aren't dissolved yet and
there's generally no ph adjusters in
them so when these tiny crystals of
ascorbic acid do actually dissolve you
end up with tiny puddles of really
concentrated ascorbic acid at low ph on
your skin and some people's skin is fine
with this but a lot of people including
me we do get a bit of stinging and
irritation so i like to mix it with
another product in my hand before
applying it to try to get that ascorbic
acid to dissolve and get a low
concentration before it hits my skin i
usually use the paula's choice two
percent bha liquid for this but it might
be too much for a lot of people's skin
because double acid so maybe use a toner
the downsides are that the texture can
be really tricky again mixing can help
and sometimes it's still too much for
some people's skin i wouldn't recommend
these sorts of products at all if your
skin can't handle a regular water-based
ascorbic acid product but if your skin
can handle them and you want a product
where you can leave it in the corner for
a year and it'll still be good this is a
great option this is one category that i
almost forgot actually there's probably
tons of categories i've forgotten but
micro needle patches with ascorbic acid
inside the solid needles after you apply
the patch the ascorbic acid in the
needles go into your skin a little bit
and then they dissolve there acro spot
eraser and zip sticker hypophae both
have ascorbic acid in them but it's not
really the star ingredient these are
only really good for spots like acne
marks and they usually have other
pigment fading ingredients in them as
well so that is seven or eight separate
categories of ascorbic acid products let
me know if i've missed any and that's
just ascorbic acid so far i'm going to
come at you with ascorbic acid
derivatives in part two these are good
options if you don't like the smell or
staining or irritation or stability
issues of ascorbic acid but you do
sacrifice some of that guaranteed
efficacy in the first column of the lab
muffin matrix like subscribe follow
check out my other videos check out my
blog check out my exfoliation guide and
care guide if you haven't already and i
will see you next time for more nerding
out